-Our volcano God is angry there must be a sacrifice
-yes a sacrifice
-No please I dont want to die (akward girly voice)
-Sacrifice.......
-No...Noo....No. Ahhhhh......(again a akward girly voice)
Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop
Today we are going to be  trying out another comment request
The idea for this video comes from Hans wurst
Who says he wants to see us put some candy gummy bear into
Some molten salt, so we've got a crucible. We've got some salt
We've got our furnace in we've have some gummy bears and some gummy worms
So we're gonna see what happens if we drop these into hot molten liquid salt alright. We've got our salt
Let's pour it into the crucible to get it melting
(Awesome music plays in background)
We have this baking glass which is designed for fairly high temperatures
And it would be nice if we could have our molten salt in it so we can really see what's going on through the side of the container
However this container is designed to withstand being put in the oven, but that's not the same as pouring
2,000 degree molten salt onto it
Now as a first test we are going to see if we can pour our salt into this glass container
And it's been in the oven heating up so it's about 550 degrees right now
But I still suspect that when I pour this in it's just gonna shatter there goes
Just a little bit of time
Yep, that's about what I thought would happen
(Awesome replay)
Well now we need to refill our salt supply and get melting again
Exciting when you light it like that
All right, we've got our molten hot salt now, let's see what happens if we introduce a gummy bear into it here goes
Well it burns quickly, I'm just going to drop it in oh
It caught on fire
It wasn't even in the salt. It just being that near it caught onfire
hmm smells
delightful
hint of burnt marshmallow maybe
Beautiful, let's try a worm see what happens
It's interesting that as it is burning up it also cools down the surface salt right near it and
Does cause it to solidify a little bit in places? It is burning just smells like burning sugar?
Gross....
Oh it had like a an outer crust and a burnt oh and the burned up inside. Just fell back in
Dee-lightful
Flaming ball of burning
Salty sugar down here. It's still hot enough that it's boiling away. That's our blob of like five gummy bears
It's not giving up without a fight
And our salt has now turned to this weird slush
Not Completely liquid
Not completely solid take our salt crucible put it back in the furnace and let this melt back down
Three two one
That is a lot of thick smoke yellowy. Gross looking smoke gross
It's like the worst looking thing I've ever seen that is so...
gross
You want to use my tongs it's gonna ruin my tongs. I need like
Something more disposable than tongs a small stick perfect
So now the salt has cooled down to the point where it's solidified, but the gummy bears and gummy worms of course are just
liquefied from the heat this is
Super disgusting that's just burning and turning black in
Truly vile and they never get this painful
Just smells like burned sugar really for the most part
It's got my worst tongs, they're already ruined
(Plays with the disgusting gummy slime)
Yeah, this is just something that's straight out of a horror film
That does look pretty
Fantastically gross, I don't know how well we're gonna be able to clean this pan out. I'm gonna do this
Ackhg...
As this cools down. It is still kind of a gummy texture. It hasn't solidified into something solid, and maybe that's just because it's still warm
It's not hot just warm and it's still pretty squishy. Just pure
melted
Resolidified salt chunks, though
There you have it that is what happens if you combine gummy bears and gummi worms with molten salt
It's a ooey-gooey burned disgusting mess
But it is interesting to see how these things react the sugar did light on fire in the salt
That was kind of cool to see we would get sort of a black burnt crust and then there would still be a little bit
Of unburned gummy bear or gummy worm down inside it, but there you have it
Thanks again to Hans wurst for your suggestion for this video check your youtube inbox. We're sending you 25 bucks
Thanks for joining us for this video and remember to come gear yourself up with hats shirts and other cool merch at the king of
Random com see you there
Aaaaaaa....(Random epic shot)
Yeah, I'll just be random happens